[SPEAKER_00] 僕の昨年はコロナ1年目の年に高校入学なので
[SPEAKER_00] 部活動とかは活発にできなかったという関係もあったんですが
[SPEAKER_00] コロナ禍で休校だった時にデータサイエンスに出会いまして
[SPEAKER_00] YouTubeの方で名目と実質の見方について
[SPEAKER_00] ここに名目で数字を見がちですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 実質で見ないと本当に増えているのか
[SPEAKER_00] それとも減少に向かっているのかが分かりづらいという話を聞きまして
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり数字を見るだけじゃダメだと
[SPEAKER_00] データの裏を読むというか
[SPEAKER_00] しっかり実態を見なければダメだなというふうに感じまして
[SPEAKER_00] これを学ぶのがデータサイエンスだというのに
[SPEAKER_00] そこで出会いまして
[SPEAKER_00] それでデータサイエンスを学びたいなと
[SPEAKER_00] いうふうに感じまして
[SPEAKER_00] 考えました
[SPEAKER_01] ここで学校に来た時にYouTubeをしたんですか
[SPEAKER_00] そういうのが
[SPEAKER_00] 統計学の教授の中の動画を拝見させていただいて
[SPEAKER_00] それはコロナの感染者数のところで書いてありまして
[SPEAKER_00] いわゆる統計学的なところがメインになってくるので
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに私は考えていたので
[SPEAKER_00] 実際はデータサイエンスはものすごく言葉の定義が
[SPEAKER_00] 広くて
[SPEAKER_00] 今は何がデータサイエンスなのか分からない
[SPEAKER_00] みたいなところになっていて
[SPEAKER_00] エンジニアとかも使っているんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 最初は統計学でちゃんと数字を見れるようにしよう
[SPEAKER_00] というところで
[SPEAKER_00] 当時数学もすごく得意だったので
[SPEAKER_00] 今ちょっとカリキュラム変わって
[SPEAKER_00] 高校でも学ぶようになったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 大学で学ぶような統計学を勉強したり
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに思っています
[SPEAKER_01] 開けて
[SPEAKER_01] 今後通えるようになったらどういうことだと思いましたか
[SPEAKER_00] 普通に高校生活を送っていたというところで
[SPEAKER_00] 中高一貫校なので
[SPEAKER_00] 新しい友達というのは入ってきにくいというか
[SPEAKER_00] 中学の友達とそのまま
[SPEAKER_00] コロナ禍の中でも制限された中でも楽しむということと
[SPEAKER_00] あと文化祭のチーフもやすいじゃないですか
[SPEAKER_00] クラスの出し物の
[SPEAKER_01] リーダー的な存在
[SPEAKER_00] 高校1年の時は
[SPEAKER_00] 結構完成者数増加してるみたいなところで
[SPEAKER_00] 外部のお客さんとかも入れられない状況だったので
[SPEAKER_00] 学校的に著作権フリーの環境で
[SPEAKER_00] バルーンアートをやろうということになりまして
[SPEAKER_00] トトロとかネコバスとか
[SPEAKER_00] そういうのをバルーンで作って
[SPEAKER_00] というのをやりました
[SPEAKER_01] ここに基地があるんですか?
[SPEAKER_00] 高校2年生の時もチーフやってまして
[SPEAKER_00] この時はジェットコースターを教室内に作って
[SPEAKER_00] そういうことをやりました
[SPEAKER_01] チーフは立候補する?
[SPEAKER_00] そうです
[SPEAKER_01] お祭り系が好き?
[SPEAKER_00] 中学の頃からチーフずっとやってて
[SPEAKER_00] 自分で立候補したのもあるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 先生とか友達からの達成もあって
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] あのー
[SPEAKER_00] 一人だけじゃないんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 他の友達と一緒に作り上げてきました
[SPEAKER_01] チーフは何人かやってますか?
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] メイントップというか
[SPEAKER_00] 一番上の人が僕で
[SPEAKER_00] ですけどあんまりそこ差がなく
[SPEAKER_00] いろんな
[SPEAKER_00] 5、6人くらいですかね
分担してやる
[SPEAKER_01] 集大成が高校の時?
[SPEAKER_00] そうです
[SPEAKER_01] OK
[SPEAKER_01] 中学と文化祭のチーフにやられて
[SPEAKER_01] 本人の集大成の時にこれができてよかったなと思ってらっしゃいます
[SPEAKER_00] そうです
[SPEAKER_00] まあぶっちゃけた話をすると
[SPEAKER_00] 中学2年生の時の文化祭が一番成功して
[SPEAKER_00] それを超えるのにずっと勤しんでたみたいなところはありまして
[SPEAKER_00] 中学2年生の時が中高全体で韓国同院生2位を達成して
[SPEAKER_01] え、じゃあ高校のクラスで?
[SPEAKER_00] そうなんですよね
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] 1位は劇をやってる体育館帰って劇やるクラスが一番だったんで
[SPEAKER_00] そこには勝てなかったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 中学2年生としては頑張っただろうというところで
[SPEAKER_00] だったんで
[SPEAKER_00] 観客同員数っていう集計の仕方は
[SPEAKER_00] 高校生の時はもうなくなってたんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] コロナの関係もあって
[SPEAKER_00] 人数も全然
[SPEAKER_00] 母体の数が違うのであんまり意味がなかったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 先生からの投票では優秀賞をいただいて
[SPEAKER_00] 最優秀賞っていうのが表向きじゃなくて裏引きというか
[SPEAKER_00] 優秀賞っていうクラスが選ばれている中で
[SPEAKER_00] 実は最優秀だったよという
[SPEAKER_00] そういうところがどうかしたんですか?
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりジェットコースターって
[SPEAKER_00] 結局、先生とか難しいので
[SPEAKER_00] ここはいろんな先生の判断を見ながらというのと
[SPEAKER_00] 生徒会とかなり協力しながら
[SPEAKER_00] 安全性にかなり注力して
[SPEAKER_00] やったというのと
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり今までジェットコースターやってるクラスがなかったんですよ
[SPEAKER_00] 歴代っていうやっぱり面白性というか
[SPEAKER_00] インパクトもあったってところで
[SPEAKER_01] 確かになんか
[SPEAKER_01] でも安全性に配慮しすぎると面白くない
[SPEAKER_01] 面白さを追求すると危なくて
[SPEAKER_00] 販売も難しい
[SPEAKER_01] 作り方みたいなのをやってる?
[SPEAKER_00] 予算がすごく限られてるので
[SPEAKER_00] 木材買ってくるとかを
[SPEAKER_00] 結構苦しかったので
[SPEAKER_00] ここは廃材とかを
[SPEAKER_00] ただで譲ってくださる方をネットで探してきて
[SPEAKER_00] 当時僕らは免許持ってなかったんで
[SPEAKER_00] 先生が車出してくれて
[SPEAKER_00] 何往復かして木材取りに行ったりでしたりとか
[SPEAKER_01] 購入の時一番大変だったのはどんなことですか?
[SPEAKER_00] 最初はクラスで案が出て
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり結構みんなが出てくるんですけども
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね最初はクラスで案が出てやっぱりみんなが出てくるんですけども
[SPEAKER_00] 最初はクラスで案が出てやっぱりみんなが出てくるんですけども
[SPEAKER_00] 最初はクラスで案が出てくるんですけども
[SPEAKER_00] 面白そうだったので
[SPEAKER_00] YouTubeでも他の学校でやってらっしゃるのを見て
[SPEAKER_00] こういうのいいねってなったんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり危ないので
[SPEAKER_00] すごく危ないので
[SPEAKER_00] 先生方の説得して協力を取り付けるというか
[SPEAKER_00] OKをもらうところが非常に大変でした
[SPEAKER_01] そうですか、安全性の説得の方は?
[SPEAKER_00] 安全性の配慮をどういう風にしてくださるのかというと
[SPEAKER_00] どうしたらOKが出るかというのも
[SPEAKER_00] いろんな先生、単人の先生だけじゃなくて
[SPEAKER_00] 学年主任とか副校長先生にも交渉しましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 生徒会もある分科会に大きく関わっているので
[SPEAKER_00] 生徒会の先生にも交渉しましたし
[SPEAKER_00] というところで
[SPEAKER_00] そうなんですね
[SPEAKER_01] で、こういうコーナーをクリアしたらやってもいいんですね
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] で、当日の運用というか
[SPEAKER_00] 何人いて
[SPEAKER_00] どこに人がいてというのを細かく報告して
[SPEAKER_01] なるほど
[SPEAKER_00] あの時は単人の先生だけじゃ見切れないので
[SPEAKER_00] 学年の先生方が変わる変わる見切られているというところで
[SPEAKER_00] ここも協力していただきました
なるほど、当日は先生もいるんですか?
先生も、はい
一緒どうですか?
[SPEAKER_00] 上からどうしますか?
[SPEAKER_00] ちょっとずっと回るだけなんですけど
いきよいよくいく
ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_01] では、そういう感じで現役で選手を頂きましたね
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 大学受験の勉強はいつ頃から始まりましたか?
[SPEAKER_00] 僕はもともと英語が苦手だったので
[SPEAKER_00] 英語だけは高校2年生くらいの時から通っていたんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 単語がすごくネックになっていて
[SPEAKER_00] 日本史も得意でしたし、数学も得意でしたし、
[SPEAKER_00] 日本史も得意でしたし数学も得意だったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 英語は今拝見がたくさん
[SPEAKER_00] 英語が半分くらい占めているので
[SPEAKER_00] そこでかなり苦戦して
[SPEAKER_01] 先週大学は第1種目でしょ
[SPEAKER_00] 第3、4、5くらい
[SPEAKER_00] 失礼止め
[SPEAKER_00] 先週大学受からなかったら老人だなと思ってたんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 先週大学なら経済学を学べるしデータサイエンスを学べる大学を
[SPEAKER_00] 一応3校選んで第3、4、5が先週大学だと思って
[SPEAKER_00] だったらいいのかな
[SPEAKER_00] 学時代で受かっていただいて
[SPEAKER_01] 1年生徒としたことで大体10とすると何にどのくらい取っていますか
[SPEAKER_00] それは学業とか
[SPEAKER_00] 学業が
[SPEAKER_00] 4
[SPEAKER_00] ,5年くらいですかね
[SPEAKER_00] 今長期インターンをデータサイエンスとしてやらせていただいていて
[SPEAKER_00] 1年くらい経つんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] その前は
[SPEAKER_00] 塾講師の個別指導室のアルバイトをやっていて
[SPEAKER_00] それも大学1年生の後半くらいからやっているので
[SPEAKER_00] 長期インターンとバイトを1回目にさせていただくと
[SPEAKER_00] あと残り6バイトを長期インターンにさせていただくと
[SPEAKER_01] この中で
[SPEAKER_01] 石田さん
[SPEAKER_01] そしてこれが一番頑張られたなと思っていらっしゃるのは
[SPEAKER_01] 長期インターンで
[SPEAKER_01] 中で周囲を巻き込みながら何か一つ何か
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] こちらのプロジェクトは
[SPEAKER_00] 蔵木様の自動化をする業務ですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 上司の方から
[SPEAKER_00] ほとんどプレゼントをさせていただいて
[SPEAKER_00] 蔵木様のような業務は上司が行っていますので
[SPEAKER_00] ですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] ほとんど送る文面とかも僕が考えてやっているので
[SPEAKER_00] 本当に責任だけ取ってくださるという形で
[SPEAKER_00] やらせていただいていて
[SPEAKER_00] その中でも僕は文系出身ということもありますし
[SPEAKER_00] 専門的にクラウドとかの操作を持っているわけではないので
[SPEAKER_00] ここは会社で関係している方との連携をしながら
[SPEAKER_00] 完全自動化に向けて
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] , 実際に載せる部分でも
[SPEAKER_00] 僕の力だけじゃできなかったので
[SPEAKER_00] 他の方々だったり
[SPEAKER_00] あと上司の方を煽りながら
[SPEAKER_00] 完全自動化ということと
[SPEAKER_00] あとはクライアントの目指す
[SPEAKER_00] 手がかからないといいますか
[SPEAKER_00] 既存の特殊的な業務を回収するというところ
[SPEAKER_00] これについては務めました
[SPEAKER_00] はい
はい
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 僕らのデータをやる側の人間と
[SPEAKER_00] あと先方の担当者
[SPEAKER_00] MDの担当者というのは
[SPEAKER_00] 実際にExcelを装置しながら
[SPEAKER_00] 作業をなさった方で
[SPEAKER_00] そちらの方と僕らは
[SPEAKER_00] データに関する知識とか
[SPEAKER_00] あるいはクラウド上の知識を
[SPEAKER_00] かなり差があるので
[SPEAKER_00] こちらについて
[SPEAKER_00] 僕らも伝え忘れた部分があるんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 分かっているよねと思いながら
[SPEAKER_00] 進めていた部分も
[SPEAKER_00] そこで見事分かっている部分があるとか
[SPEAKER_00] あとは名前規則
[SPEAKER_00] ファイル名の名前規則とか
[SPEAKER_00] この辺りきれいに一致させないと
[SPEAKER_00] よくなかったというところを
[SPEAKER_00] 非常に反省しました
[SPEAKER_01] 今おっしゃってくださったデータの理解に
[SPEAKER_01] 差があるみたいなところ
[SPEAKER_01] これはあれですかね
[SPEAKER_01] 財務部の資料作成の事業家とか
[SPEAKER_01] その会社のPSとかPLとか
[SPEAKER_01] 資料に落とし込むみたいな
[SPEAKER_00] そうはその
[SPEAKER_00] その
[SPEAKER_00] えっと
[SPEAKER_00] お金関係
[SPEAKER_00] 分付金とかのところの
[SPEAKER_00] 集計作業というか
[SPEAKER_00] そういうのを行っていて
[SPEAKER_00] 毎月経営陣に提出する
[SPEAKER_00] 何月分の請求で
[SPEAKER_00] 何月分の利用面が入りました
[SPEAKER_00] みたいなのをまとめてある資料
[SPEAKER_00] っていうのを毎月
[SPEAKER_00] こちらの資料作成と
[SPEAKER_00] その前の売りかけ金を
[SPEAKER_00] 顧客会議
[SPEAKER_00] 顧客会議を
[SPEAKER_00] 顧客ごとにまとめてるエクセルファイルがあって
[SPEAKER_00] こちらの集計作業というか
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] 反映作業
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] それぞれの項目の理解に差がある
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] この列がこういうのがある方がいいとか
[SPEAKER_00] 例えば日付のカラムでも
[SPEAKER_00] 何年何月何日って書いてあるやつ
[SPEAKER_00] あの漢字で年月日って書いてあるパターンと
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] ,で書いてあるパターンと
[SPEAKER_00] スラッシュで書いてあるパターンで
[SPEAKER_00] こちら側としては入力が全然変わってくる
[SPEAKER_00] というのと
[SPEAKER_00] それだと
[SPEAKER_00] 我々が集計する
[SPEAKER_00] ここから何日後のデータとかっていう
[SPEAKER_00] 処理をするときに
[SPEAKER_00] 年月日とかだと
[SPEAKER_00] 漢字だと厳しいですね
[SPEAKER_00] これかなり厳しいので
[SPEAKER_00] 一回変換する必要があって
[SPEAKER_00] いったりするので
[SPEAKER_00] 他はあとは
[SPEAKER_00] 資料を実際に資料を見せるときに
[SPEAKER_00] 経営人が見やすいように年月に直してくださいとか
[SPEAKER_00] 配分じゃなくて年月日とか
[SPEAKER_00] そういうところは
[SPEAKER_00] かなり細かい要項をいただいて
[SPEAKER_01] そういうことか
[SPEAKER_00] その辺をすり合わせていくのが
[SPEAKER_00] 細かいけど重要なところ
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり完全再現となると
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりそこがかなり重要になってくるというか
[SPEAKER_01] そうかそうかお客様としては
[SPEAKER_01] これまでに何かと言ったことがあるのに
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化されていく
[SPEAKER_00] あとは
[SPEAKER_00] 解約日っていう
[SPEAKER_00] 課題もあって
[SPEAKER_00] また解約されていないお客様って
[SPEAKER_00] 解約日ってないじゃないですか
[SPEAKER_00] なのでここは本来
[SPEAKER_00] 空欄とか
[SPEAKER_00] あとはExcelでは
[SPEAKER_00] 1900年1月0日みたいな
[SPEAKER_00] ありえない日付が
[SPEAKER_00] 入っているような処理に
[SPEAKER_00] 今までしていたんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 僕らとしては不可能なんですよね
[SPEAKER_00] コードを書く上では
[SPEAKER_00] できなかったので
[SPEAKER_00] こちらの空欄でいいかっていう話とか
[SPEAKER_00] 空欄の方が僕らも集計とかやりやすいので
[SPEAKER_00] そういうふうに
[SPEAKER_00] 僕らサイドでやりやすいように
[SPEAKER_00] 特にそこで
[SPEAKER_00] 集計作業で
[SPEAKER_00] ミスとかが起きない
[SPEAKER_00] というのに関しての交渉とか
[SPEAKER_00] 行わせていただきました
[SPEAKER_01] ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_01] そういったクライアントさんの
[SPEAKER_01] 窓口なりにくくりとかしてたとか
[SPEAKER_01] そのやりとりっていうのは
[SPEAKER_01] 石田さん
[SPEAKER_01] あ、違う
[SPEAKER_01] 上司の方
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 上司の方が窓口になってるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 僕が裏
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_01] このプロジェクトは
[SPEAKER_01] 何の関係っつうのか
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 今年の1月から
[SPEAKER_00] 3月ぐらいまでやって
[SPEAKER_00] 4ヶ月ぐらいやってまして
[SPEAKER_00] 今はその次の
[SPEAKER_00] それを利用した
[SPEAKER_00] 次の
[SPEAKER_00] 作業をやる
[SPEAKER_00] 自動販売を担当させていただいてます
[SPEAKER_00] 同じお会社で
[SPEAKER_01] そうです
[SPEAKER_01] 次のプロジェクト
[SPEAKER_01] 4ヶ月間はどれくらい経ったんですか
[SPEAKER_00] 3月、4月は月100時間くらい
[SPEAKER_00] 1月、2月もテストありつつ
[SPEAKER_00] なんだかんだ70時間から80時間は
[SPEAKER_01] 経ったと思います
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] トータル350時間
[SPEAKER_01] 平日毎日をして
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね、ほぼそれくらい
[SPEAKER_01] 1日5時間くらい
[SPEAKER_01] もう結構頑張りました
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね、大学がある日は
[SPEAKER_00] 午後3時間とか4時間だけ
[SPEAKER_00] 授業ない日は
[SPEAKER_00] もう丸々ほぼ8時間
[SPEAKER_00] たまに寝坊して
[SPEAKER_00] 7時間になる時もあるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] へえ
[SPEAKER_01] これはお会社に出社するんですか
[SPEAKER_01] インターン先に
[SPEAKER_00] 水曜日と金曜日が出社日になっているので
[SPEAKER_00] ここ以外リモートで
[SPEAKER_00] 他の社員も来ないので
[SPEAKER_01] 僕も家でやってる
[SPEAKER_01] 4ヶ月間かなり頑張られたと聞いたけど
[SPEAKER_01] どんなところが面白くて
[SPEAKER_01] モチベーションになったのかと思うのですが
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね、やっぱり新しい考え方というか
[SPEAKER_00] 視点を身につけるところがありましたし
[SPEAKER_00] また色々思うことがあったりするので
[SPEAKER_00] 思い出させられたというか
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり自分は文系出身で
[SPEAKER_00] それでデータサイエンスのことにも理解があって
[SPEAKER_00] 知識があるので
[SPEAKER_00] 文系の気持ちを
[SPEAKER_00] データとかわからない人たちの気持ちを理解してる
[SPEAKER_00] っていうマインドでやってたつもりが
[SPEAKER_00] ここに入ることができてなかったっていう
[SPEAKER_00] 反省がありましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 逆にその先進的な見方というか
[SPEAKER_00] 考え方として
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりAIにデータが出てくるときに
[SPEAKER_00] データを食わせるというか
[SPEAKER_00] 接続するのにどういう基盤を作ったらよいのか
[SPEAKER_00] っていうところも非常に考えさせられることになりましたので
[SPEAKER_01] この先進化はAIは出てくるんですか?
[SPEAKER_00] AIって言葉ってすごい広いので
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化もいわゆる本当にAIっていう括りになってしまうんですよ
[SPEAKER_00] 大きな括りで言うと
[SPEAKER_01] マクロとかじゃなくて?
[SPEAKER_00] じゃなくてですね
[SPEAKER_00] 本当にこう
[SPEAKER_00] SQLを使ってコードを書いていってるので
[SPEAKER_00] これを使ってアウトプット
[SPEAKER_00] 自動で出てくるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] これもこういう意味ではAIに対応するんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] でもゆくゆくは
[SPEAKER_00] クラウド上でAIに質問しただけで
[SPEAKER_00] 何年何月のコードは
[SPEAKER_00] なんで売りかけ金が少ないのかっていうことを
[SPEAKER_00] そこから分析させるっていうこともやりたいと
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに今
[SPEAKER_00] 会社で考えてるんですけど
[SPEAKER_01] その先々を見据えて
[SPEAKER_01] 今のデータ制御をする
[SPEAKER_01] みたいなのを考えればすごく面白かったですし
[SPEAKER_00] これこのプロジェクトやってる4ヶ月の間で
[SPEAKER_00] こういうふうにやっていこうっていう話に
[SPEAKER_00] 会社でもそうですし
[SPEAKER_00] クライアント様とお話させていただいてる中でも
[SPEAKER_00] そういうお話があったので
[SPEAKER_00] そういう接近しないといけないし
[SPEAKER_00] そこで移行しやすいように
[SPEAKER_00] やっていかないといけないというふうに思っています
[SPEAKER_00] 認識改めました
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] プロジェクトは石田さんと
[SPEAKER_01] インターン先の企業だと
[SPEAKER_01] どんな方がいるとしますか
[SPEAKER_00] 上司がいて
[SPEAKER_00] あとクラウドの操作の担当者がいます
[SPEAKER_00] いわゆるクラウドエンジニアに呼ばれる職業の方と
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_01] じゃあその方とも
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね
[SPEAKER_01] どんなデータの出力
[SPEAKER_01] アウトプットにしてもらったりとかも話されていますか
[SPEAKER_00] というよりは
[SPEAKER_00] アウトプットの出力に関しては
[SPEAKER_00] 上司とクライアントとお話しするんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] それをAIに接続する前の
[SPEAKER_00] 基盤を整理する段階として
[SPEAKER_00] クラウドでもどこにこういうデータを置いといて
[SPEAKER_00] どういうふうに分割してデータを置いとけば
[SPEAKER_00] 引っ張ってきやすいかっていう話なんですけど
[SPEAKER_01] そういうやり取りも上司じゃなくて石田さんが
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] あとクラウド担当者の方も
[SPEAKER_00] データサイエンスチームとして今上司として
[SPEAKER_00] やり取りしてくださっています
[SPEAKER_01] やり取り
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 結構クラウド
[SPEAKER_00] リモートワークは周囲があるので
[SPEAKER_00] ここでテキストベースのコミュニケーションになりがちなので
[SPEAKER_00] ここで対面じゃないので相互が生まれたりとか
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] 僕も表現統一できていないところがあって
[SPEAKER_00] うまく伝えられなかった部分とかがありましたので
[SPEAKER_00] 相互がありそうだなと思ったらすぐ
[SPEAKER_00] Googleとかで直接お話させていただいて
[SPEAKER_00] なるほど
[SPEAKER_00] 相互解消をしようと
[SPEAKER_00] 学生のインターンシップは結構多いんですか
[SPEAKER_00] 僕の会社がもうすごい15人もいない会社になってて
[SPEAKER_00] 僕が入ってからずっと一人で
[SPEAKER_00] 4月から今もう一人エンジニアワークをして
[SPEAKER_00] プロダクト作り側のエンジニアで
[SPEAKER_00] 今大学2年生の子が
[SPEAKER_01] 学生インターンは一人という
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_01] その会社の社会人の皆さんも結構すぐ信頼している
[SPEAKER_00] そうです
[SPEAKER_00] 一緒に仕事しているデータサイエンスチームが
[SPEAKER_00] 僕と上司ともう一人の先輩社員の3人だけなので
[SPEAKER_00] この3人でちょっと仕事をしていますけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 入社後すぐ飲み会とかもありましたし
[SPEAKER_00] かなり仲良くさせていただいて
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 年上の方も
[SPEAKER_00] 社長とかは20個ぐらい上なんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 比較的全体的に若い会社なので
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり接しやすいですし
[SPEAKER_00] 僕の上司も15個ぐらい上なんです
[SPEAKER_00] 30前半なので
[SPEAKER_00] かなり若いので
[SPEAKER_01] 話しやすい
[SPEAKER_01] 講師バイトを辞めて
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] これやっぱりデータサイエンスとして
[SPEAKER_01] 働いてみたいなと思います
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 僕が
[SPEAKER_00] 文系っていうコンプレックスじゃないんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり今大学でも
[SPEAKER_00] データサイエンス学部とかが新設されている中で
[SPEAKER_00] 専門的に学んでいる方々と
[SPEAKER_00] データサイエンスの知識で
[SPEAKER_00] かなり差が生まれるので
[SPEAKER_00] ここはどういう風に埋めようかって考えた時に
[SPEAKER_00] 経験で埋めたいという風に考えましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 実際の業務に触れて
[SPEAKER_00] 理論で学んでいたことと実際が違うということ
[SPEAKER_00] かなりそういうところを学びたいという風に思いましたので
[SPEAKER_00] ずっと長期インターン探していた
[SPEAKER_00] ようやくデータサイエンスとかの
[SPEAKER_00] データサイエンスリストの募集をあるサイトを見つけて
[SPEAKER_00] 去年の2月頃に入社しました
[SPEAKER_01] 講師の時は?
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 個別指導職?
[SPEAKER_00] はい個別指導職です
[SPEAKER_01] これは年代として?
[SPEAKER_00] 小学生から高校生まで
[SPEAKER_01] 結構幅広い
[SPEAKER_00] 幅広いです
[SPEAKER_01] 何を教えていましたか?
[SPEAKER_00] 小学生までで全員で
[SPEAKER_00] 高校生は文教の参画と
[SPEAKER_00] あと日本語と英語も
[SPEAKER_00] 全員大きいでしょって言われて
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] 基本的には文法とかからだったので
[SPEAKER_00] 受験前になるとやっぱり自分でも解かないといけなくて
[SPEAKER_00] 大変だったんですけど
[SPEAKER_01] はい、やりきりました
[SPEAKER_00] 自分が学んでて自分が理解してたものも
[SPEAKER_00] 言葉にして伝えるってすごく難しいっていうことと
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりあと日本史、特に日本史なんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりイデオロギーを入れずにどうやって伝えるかってかなり難しいんだなと
[SPEAKER_00] 難しいんだなっていうところは感じました
[SPEAKER_01] 教職では他の先生と保護者さんとのやりとりは?
[SPEAKER_00] いや保護者様とのやりとりはほとんどなくて
[SPEAKER_00] 生徒が遅刻してきたりとかいった場合は
[SPEAKER_00] 会員が面談中とかいない場合があったので
[SPEAKER_00] その時は僕らが連絡させていただくっていうことで接点はあったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 実際に対面でやりとりするってことはほとんどなかったです
[SPEAKER_00] 同僚というか
[SPEAKER_00] 他の塾講師ほとんど大学生なので
[SPEAKER_00] 僕はかなり仲良くなっています
[SPEAKER_00] 今でも仲良いです
[SPEAKER_00] 1年ちょっと経ちますけど
[SPEAKER_01] どうみたいですか?
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 結構10人くらい集まって
[SPEAKER_01] ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_01] 塾講師の同僚たちのためにというと変なんですけど
[SPEAKER_01] 全体のクオリティを底上げしていくというものが何かどうかって
[SPEAKER_01] もしあれば
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] ちょっと細かい話になるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 僕ら都立指導塾って
[SPEAKER_00] 1人の講師につき3人が教えるんです
[SPEAKER_00] しかも学年も違うし
[SPEAKER_00] 教科も違うっていうところで
[SPEAKER_00] かなり大変なんですよね
[SPEAKER_00] 教えたりとか
[SPEAKER_00] 時間が入ると80分という中で
[SPEAKER_00] 3人なので20分弱くらい時間がかかっていて
[SPEAKER_01] 3人同時に?
[SPEAKER_01] そうなんです
[SPEAKER_00] 3人?大変なんだ
[SPEAKER_00] でも頭ごちゃごちゃになりますし
本当だ
[SPEAKER_00] なのでちゃんと教えられる時間が20分くらいしかないので
[SPEAKER_00] それ以外は演習をさせないといけないっていうので
[SPEAKER_00] 事前準備もいろいろ必要ですし
[SPEAKER_00] あと宿題もちゃんと出して
[SPEAKER_00] どこ理解してる理解してないっていうのを把握しないといけないんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 毎回同じ講師が同じことを話すわけじゃない
[SPEAKER_01] それも違うんですか?
[SPEAKER_00] そうなんです
[SPEAKER_00] なのでちゃんと決意しないといけないんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 本学は結構自由欄みたいな感じで
[SPEAKER_00] フリー記述
[SPEAKER_00] そうなんですよね
[SPEAKER_00] 宿題のページ数とか今回やったところぐらいは
[SPEAKER_00] 他の自由記述みたいな空白空欄になってるところは
[SPEAKER_00] 本当に先生方の裁量に任されて書いてるので
[SPEAKER_00] ここはやっぱりフォーマットを持ちないと
[SPEAKER_00] 自分の解像力がないので
[SPEAKER_00] 文字改善ですることができないですし
[SPEAKER_00] 何やったのかっていうのをちゃんと引き継ぎ書で
[SPEAKER_00] 広告書で理解しておけば
[SPEAKER_00] じゃあ前回あれだったから今回大丈夫か確認しようっていうところで
[SPEAKER_00] すぐ入れますし
[SPEAKER_00] そのための準備もできるはずが
[SPEAKER_00] 広告書で引き継ぎできないと
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり前回何やったのとか
[SPEAKER_00] どこでつながっているのっていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] きっちりと把握してからじゃないと動き出せないってところで
[SPEAKER_00] そこがスタートダッシュが遅いと
[SPEAKER_00] 使う時間が長くなってしまうし
[SPEAKER_00] 教える時間をやっぱり大切にしたいと思ってたので
[SPEAKER_00] そこの時間を確保するために
[SPEAKER_00] 引き継ぎ書を書くようにフォーマットを
[SPEAKER_01] フォーマットは広告を足りない?
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] まず宿題をやったかやってないかと
[SPEAKER_00] やってるけどここを間違えた?
[SPEAKER_00] 間違えた部分とか
[SPEAKER_00] 何が理解できてなくて
[SPEAKER_00] これ間違えたのかっていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] 理解してほしくて
[SPEAKER_00] そこを次回口頭で確認したら
[SPEAKER_00] 口頭で確認でも良いですし
[SPEAKER_00] もう一回同じ宿題の部分を
[SPEAKER_00] 最初やっていって
[SPEAKER_00] 理解を維持することもできると思うので
[SPEAKER_00] まずここの段階を維持していたっていうところと
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり
[SPEAKER_00] 確かに社会とか理科だったら
[SPEAKER_00] 知識が足りなくて正解できなかったって
[SPEAKER_00] まあまああると思うんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 数学とかだと
[SPEAKER_00] 一次関数理解してなかったから
[SPEAKER_00] 二次関数理解できてないとか
[SPEAKER_00] そもそも関数が分かってない
[SPEAKER_00] XIが分かってないとかっていう
[SPEAKER_00] どこに興味があるのかっていうのも
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり表面的なところだと
[SPEAKER_00] 理解できないというか
[SPEAKER_00] 根本的に探さないといけないし
[SPEAKER_00] ここをやっぱ長きに分かって
[SPEAKER_00] 長期的に治療していく
[SPEAKER_00] 処方していって
[SPEAKER_00] それで改善していくし
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱ現状にたどり着くことが
[SPEAKER_00] 難しいと思っているので
[SPEAKER_00] 根本的にできてもらって
[SPEAKER_00] 今回それをやりつつ
[SPEAKER_00] 学校に行くようなものを作りましたとか
[SPEAKER_00] そういうことを書くようにお願いをして
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱこういうフォーマットに
[SPEAKER_00] 従ってくださいっていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] 他の講師の方々にお願いする必要が
[SPEAKER_00] あったので
[SPEAKER_00] みんながみんなきちんと書いてくださる方じゃなかったので
[SPEAKER_01] ちょっと細かいなみたいな
[SPEAKER_00] 雑談を書く人たちもいたので
[SPEAKER_00] 字が汚くて読めないとか
[SPEAKER_00] あるので
[SPEAKER_01] じゃあどうやってみなさんに
[SPEAKER_01] 浸透させていったのか
[SPEAKER_00] 一人ずつ
[SPEAKER_00] じっくりと時間かけて
[SPEAKER_00] お願いをして
[SPEAKER_00] こういうふうに書いてくれるとありがたいなとか
[SPEAKER_00] こういうことで困ってるんだけど
[SPEAKER_00] どうすればいいとかっていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] 実際に相談しつつ
[SPEAKER_00] 引き継ぎのことはメインで
[SPEAKER_00] 相談とか質問とか
[SPEAKER_00] それで当事者意識を持ってくださる方も
[SPEAKER_00] いらっしゃるので
[SPEAKER_00] 丁寧にコミュニケーションを取ることが
[SPEAKER_00] よかったかなと
[SPEAKER_01] 当事者意識を持ってくれる人は
[SPEAKER_01] これいいねみたいなことをやってくださって
[SPEAKER_01] ちょっと面倒くさがられる方は
[SPEAKER_01] 石田博君がそこまでいると
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] かなりのぎってたので
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり仲いいメンツには
[SPEAKER_00] 面倒くさいけどやるよ
[SPEAKER_00] みたいなところもありましたし
[SPEAKER_00] かなり週4は出勤してたので
[SPEAKER_00] 関わる先生たちも多かったので
[SPEAKER_00] それはかなり協力的にやってくださいましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 一応バイトリーダーっていう立場で
[SPEAKER_00] ずっとやってたので
[SPEAKER_01] バイトリーダーも入ってからどれくらい
[SPEAKER_00] 結構早かったですね
4ヶ月
それを社員さんにやってるんですか
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 一応テストというか講習みたいなのがあって
[SPEAKER_00] 社員の推薦があって
[SPEAKER_00] 一応バイトリーダー的に
[SPEAKER_00] プラスアルファで業務をやる部分として
[SPEAKER_00] 保護者の方に電話をする対応とか
[SPEAKER_00] あと来客の対応とかする場面もあるので
[SPEAKER_00] こういうときにどういうふうに対応しなさい
[SPEAKER_00] こういうのをやってみると
[SPEAKER_00] ペーパーテストの授業をやって
[SPEAKER_00] それから合格して
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり生徒に理解してほしいっていうのと
[SPEAKER_00] あと成績上がってほしい
[SPEAKER_00] 志望校に出てほしいっていうので
[SPEAKER_00] 1年間ずっと見てた生徒もいっぱいいたので
[SPEAKER_00] ここは本当に
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり生徒を目の前にすると
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり行ってほしい
[SPEAKER_00] 行きたいところに行ってほしい
[SPEAKER_00] っていう思いもありますし
[SPEAKER_00] 特に理由を持って
[SPEAKER_00] ここに行きたいって言ってくれる生徒
[SPEAKER_00] 結構多かったので
[SPEAKER_00] 僕が担当してる生徒は結構そういう生徒多くて
[SPEAKER_01] なるほど
[SPEAKER_00] いや
[SPEAKER_00] メンバーとして考えてほしい
[SPEAKER_01] これまでの話とか
[SPEAKER_01] うちの人生の中で
[SPEAKER_01] 一番これは自分にメンタル的に負荷がかかったのは
[SPEAKER_00] これも長期インターンで
[SPEAKER_00] 別のプロジェクトの話になるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 集計作業の自動化
[SPEAKER_00] また自動化の話になって申し訳ないんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化の話がありまして
[SPEAKER_00] 数値合わせはやっぱりしないといけないですね
[SPEAKER_00] というのも
[SPEAKER_00] 今までExcelで集計作業やってたものと
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化した結果
[SPEAKER_00] 数値がずれるっていうのは問題があるので
[SPEAKER_00] どこでゲインがあるのかっていうところを
[SPEAKER_00] 擦り合わせるっていう作業があったんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化作業をやっておきながら
[SPEAKER_00] 僕は目で見て
[SPEAKER_00] こことここが違うっていうふうに
[SPEAKER_00] やったりして
[SPEAKER_00] そうするとExcelと自動化って
[SPEAKER_00] メディアに比べて
[SPEAKER_00] そうすると間違いも出てきますし
[SPEAKER_00] ミュートシーンもありましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 合ってたのに間違ってると思ってるのとかもあったので
[SPEAKER_00] それはなぜ合ってたんだろうっていうふうに思ってたんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] そういうふうに思いましたし
[SPEAKER_00] 自動化のコードを書くのってAIにやらせたこともあって
[SPEAKER_00] 分析作業とかAI使ってやってるんですけども
[SPEAKER_00] コードがぐちゃぐちゃになって
[SPEAKER_00] 自分がわからなかったことがある
[SPEAKER_00] 集計作業でも似たようなこともあって
[SPEAKER_00] AI使って自動化効率化しようと図ったのに
[SPEAKER_00] 結局自動化できるっていうことがあって
[SPEAKER_00] AIを使うのもやっぱり使い手の能力より試されるし
[SPEAKER_00] 何をしてどういうものを作ってっていうのも
[SPEAKER_00] あらたじめ設計というか
[SPEAKER_00] しっかり考えた上で
[SPEAKER_00] AIに作業の方向にシフトさせないといけないなというふうに
[SPEAKER_00] 強く感じました
[SPEAKER_01] そういう細かい仕事の時間について見比べたりとか
[SPEAKER_00] そういったことになっちゃうと
[SPEAKER_00] これは何をやってたんだろうってなっちゃったときが
結構プレッシャーあるんですよね
[SPEAKER_00] 結構原稿化するの難しいんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] なんであそこで自分で決めてなかったんだろうっていう反省もありますし
[SPEAKER_00] 未然にふさげたことなんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 今ぐらいは自然にふさげたことなのに
[SPEAKER_00] そこでミスをしたっていうことと
[SPEAKER_00] それまで順調にいってたのに
[SPEAKER_00] なんでここで決めてたのかもあるんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] 全ては自分の事前のやり方が間違ってたっていうところなので
[SPEAKER_00] ここはやっぱり反省をして
[SPEAKER_01] これまでで一番挫折というのはどんなことですか
[SPEAKER_00] 今の経験
[SPEAKER_01] 今の経験なるほど
[SPEAKER_01] 今の経験でできたのかな
[SPEAKER_00] ですし
[SPEAKER_00] 関わってくる人たちも
[SPEAKER_00] 次の会社の人たちとか
[SPEAKER_00] クライアント先にも
[SPEAKER_00] 農機的なところで
[SPEAKER_00] ここも
[SPEAKER_00] 仕事とかビジネスなので
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり期日守れないっていうか
[SPEAKER_00] 伸びてしまうと非常に危険になってくるし
[SPEAKER_00] 信頼してくれている上司に対して
[SPEAKER_00] 申し訳がかたないといいますか
[SPEAKER_00] 任せていただいて
[SPEAKER_00] 学生だし
[SPEAKER_00] いいの失敗するじゃないんだから
[SPEAKER_00] いいんだよって
[SPEAKER_00] 言ってくださってるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] でもそれでもやっぱり
[SPEAKER_00] 上司に迷惑かけたなっていうところは
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり強く感じてたので
[SPEAKER_01] ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_01] ご自身のことは
[SPEAKER_01] 楽観的だと思うんですか
[SPEAKER_01] 悲観的だと思うんですか
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] まあ時と場合によると思うんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] どちらも全然
[SPEAKER_00] でも確かに
[SPEAKER_00] 何か払えたと思うと
[SPEAKER_00] 楽観的には思っている方です
[SPEAKER_00] ただ事前準備は一応
[SPEAKER_00] 悲観的にというか
[SPEAKER_00] 一応最悪の事態を考えて
[SPEAKER_00] 行動しようと
[SPEAKER_00] 心がけた上で
[SPEAKER_00] やらせる
[SPEAKER_01] ご自身で思う
[SPEAKER_01] 自分のここはまだちょっと
[SPEAKER_01] 硬いのかなと思っています
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] これ弱みにつながる部分なんですが
[SPEAKER_00] 自分で作業を抱え込んでしまう
[SPEAKER_00] っていう部分があります
[SPEAKER_00] この作業を抱え込むっていうのは
[SPEAKER_00] 他人の要請でお願いすることで
[SPEAKER_00] やらせるということが
[SPEAKER_00] ある程度苦手な意識というか
[SPEAKER_00] 何らかの意識について
[SPEAKER_00] 任せる相手の
[SPEAKER_00] 能力とか
[SPEAKER_00] あとは得意分野を
[SPEAKER_00] 理解した上で
[SPEAKER_00] お願いしないといけないというのは
[SPEAKER_00] 純粋に承知していること
[SPEAKER_00] ただやっぱりその作業を
[SPEAKER_00] この作業やってねって
[SPEAKER_00] お願いするよりも
[SPEAKER_00] どういう目的があって
[SPEAKER_00] 何のためにやって
[SPEAKER_00] っていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりその先のビジョンまで
[SPEAKER_00] 丁寧に説明して
[SPEAKER_00] それでこういうことを
[SPEAKER_00] やって欲しいんだけど
[SPEAKER_00] お願いできますかっていう風に
[SPEAKER_00] 説明しないと
[SPEAKER_00] 人もついてこないですし
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] ただ作業をやらせるだけだと
[SPEAKER_00] 本当にAIで良くなってしまうというか
[SPEAKER_00] なので
[SPEAKER_00] 同じビジョンに一つ一つ向かって
[SPEAKER_00] みんなでやっていく
[SPEAKER_00] っていうのを
[SPEAKER_00] 丁寧に説明しながら
[SPEAKER_00] 任せていくっていう
[SPEAKER_00] ことがやっぱり
[SPEAKER_01] 身体意識を持っている
[SPEAKER_01] なるほど
[SPEAKER_01] ちょっと作業を自分で抱え込んじゃうと
[SPEAKER_00] そういえばパンクして
[SPEAKER_01] 脳筋を食いちゃうとか
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] それはやばいなと思ったら
[SPEAKER_00] こういう感じで
[SPEAKER_00] 上司にヘルプを出すとか
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 一応事前に何でしょうか
[SPEAKER_00] 周りの方々はよく
[SPEAKER_00] コミュニケーション取ってるよねって
[SPEAKER_00] 言ってくださるんですけど
[SPEAKER_00] 僕的にはまだまだ足りないというか
[SPEAKER_00] もっと細かいところでも
[SPEAKER_00] すぐ相談すればいいのにっていう風に
[SPEAKER_00] すぐ相談して
[SPEAKER_00] コミュニケーションエラーを減らして
[SPEAKER_00] 時間をかからせないように
[SPEAKER_00] する方が良好です
[SPEAKER_00] なるほど
[SPEAKER_01] じゃあ今も周りからは
[SPEAKER_00] ちゃんと応援するって
[SPEAKER_00] できてるんだけど
[SPEAKER_01] 自分としてはもっと
[SPEAKER_00] コンパスを
[SPEAKER_00] 運営とか設営する
[SPEAKER_00] サービスに入ってまして
[SPEAKER_00] これ大学2年生から
[SPEAKER_00] 入ってるので
[SPEAKER_00] 1年生からじゃないですけど
[SPEAKER_01] それもさっきの
[SPEAKER_01] 銃の中に出てたのか
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_01] あんまり活動してないのがあって
オートミックス自体は
[SPEAKER_00] 4回ぐらいで
[SPEAKER_00] それ以外はほとんど
[SPEAKER_00] 活動してないというか
[SPEAKER_00] なので
大学の大職です
[SPEAKER_01] あと学業も
[SPEAKER_01] 一番名称が残っているのが
[SPEAKER_01] ゼミになられますか
[SPEAKER_01] そうです
[SPEAKER_01] ゼミの中では
[SPEAKER_00] 今は経済学における
[SPEAKER_00] というテーマで
[SPEAKER_01] このゼミはどんな風に進んでいるんですか
[SPEAKER_00] 一応
[SPEAKER_00] 学んでいることが
[SPEAKER_00] 経済学という中で
[SPEAKER_00] いわゆる統計的な手法を用いた
[SPEAKER_00] 手法に関する
[SPEAKER_00] 経済学が
[SPEAKER_00] この中の
[SPEAKER_00] 因果制限という
[SPEAKER_00] 相関関係って
[SPEAKER_00] あれじゃないですか
[SPEAKER_00] これって別に
[SPEAKER_00] 実際にそこが因果関係があるかは
[SPEAKER_00] 分からないというところで
[SPEAKER_00] だから因果関係をちゃんと見ていこう
[SPEAKER_00] 相関関係があるけど
[SPEAKER_00] 因果関係を見て
[SPEAKER_00] 原因があって
[SPEAKER_00] その間に
[SPEAKER_00] いろんな要因があって
[SPEAKER_00] こういう結果になっているよね
[SPEAKER_00] というのをしっかりとやめて
[SPEAKER_00] それを解除して
[SPEAKER_00] 原因と結果の純粋な
[SPEAKER_00] 関係性を見ていく
[SPEAKER_00] ということに
[SPEAKER_00] 勉強していく
[SPEAKER_00] 基本的に臨読
[SPEAKER_00] 臨読
[SPEAKER_01] 何週間かに1年
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 大体
[SPEAKER_00] 1年間で4回くらい
[SPEAKER_00] 発表する
[SPEAKER_01] 年生になったら
[SPEAKER_00] 今は卒業論文を
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 最近のところ
[SPEAKER_01] いろいろお互いできたので
[SPEAKER_00] 就活のことも
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 金融を中心に
[SPEAKER_01] IT系モビルを
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 就活の軸みたいな
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね
[SPEAKER_00] 私がやりたいことは
[SPEAKER_00] 定量分析と定性分析を
[SPEAKER_00] 掛け合わせたい
[SPEAKER_00] 組み合わせたい
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに考えていまして
[SPEAKER_00] 定性分析というのは
[SPEAKER_00] 結構今AIでできるような中で
[SPEAKER_00] 一時情報を取り入れて
[SPEAKER_00] その情報を
[SPEAKER_00] 定量分析の中に入れ合わせて
[SPEAKER_00] より高度な分析にしていきたい
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに考えていて
[SPEAKER_00] これをできる業界
[SPEAKER_00] 職業
[SPEAKER_00] というふうに考えて
[SPEAKER_01] 就職のことになりました
[SPEAKER_01] ではちょっと
[SPEAKER_01] ガシャさんの状況を
[SPEAKER_01] お伺いしたいんですが
[SPEAKER_01] 他に出ているところは
[SPEAKER_00] 他はないです
[SPEAKER_01] 今うちみたいに
[SPEAKER_01] リゾナさん
[SPEAKER_01] はい
[SPEAKER_01] 結構
[SPEAKER_00] 前にやってから
[SPEAKER_00] 連絡がないので
[SPEAKER_00] もう同じ
[SPEAKER_00] 他は今は
[SPEAKER_00] 同じだけ
中でどうして
法人構造
[SPEAKER_00] はい
[SPEAKER_00] まず
[SPEAKER_00] 後で
[SPEAKER_00] 自分で
[SPEAKER_00] 僕が
[SPEAKER_00] 作業をする
[SPEAKER_00] っていう
[SPEAKER_00] 理由としましては
[SPEAKER_00] まず
避難者のグループが
[SPEAKER_00] 人口調査進化をして
[SPEAKER_00] くれていて
[SPEAKER_00] かつ100%稼働を
[SPEAKER_00] してるということと
[SPEAKER_00] あとAIの
[SPEAKER_00] 外人とかが
[SPEAKER_00] しておりまして、温庫を死亡しました。
[SPEAKER_00] 特に法人コースを死亡している理由としましては、
[SPEAKER_00] 先ほどの軽量感染の形成分析をやりたいという話で、
[SPEAKER_00] 軽量感染って一番大事なのは一時情報で、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり一時情報を取得するのはかなり難しくて、
[SPEAKER_00] ただヒアリングするだけで、ロボットがやるヒアリングと
[SPEAKER_00] 人間がやるヒアリングってやっぱりとても違いと思っていて、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり信頼数を築いていく中で得られる情報とかもあると思うので、
[SPEAKER_00] ここの一時情報をいかにして取得して、
[SPEAKER_00] そしてこの得られた情報を軽量分析にいかにして取得するか、
[SPEAKER_00] ということをやりたいと思っていますので、
[SPEAKER_00] この一時情報を細かくというか、深いところまで
[SPEAKER_00] ヒアリングする力を身につけたいと思います。
[SPEAKER_00] 個人ホース、個人RMを指導しています。
[SPEAKER_01] ありがとうございます。
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_01] おっしゃる通り、お客様からそういった細かな情報、
[SPEAKER_01] 会社の裏側の情報まで教えていただけるようになるという
[SPEAKER_01] 信頼関係が非常に重要で、
[SPEAKER_01] お客様と信頼関係を築く、
[SPEAKER_01] こういうことを心がけたいなと今思っていらっしゃることはありますか?
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりオススメのお客様としては、
[SPEAKER_00] 自分の情報を開示すること、
[SPEAKER_00] ということになるので、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり大切な情報を開示するには、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりこちらもある程度、
[SPEAKER_01] 開示しないといけないと思うので、
[SPEAKER_00] そこはウィンウィンな関係という、
[SPEAKER_00] 家族、家の情報はあると思うんですけれども、
[SPEAKER_00] 個人的なところでもいいので、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱりお客様からの情報開示、
[SPEAKER_00] 情報を開示していって、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり信頼できる人だと感じてもらえるところを目指しています。
[SPEAKER_01] 今、先ほど産業調査部において、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 個人コースですと、
[SPEAKER_01] 最初は営業店、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] そこで個人アレンジとか、
はい。
そこから先のキャリアビジョン、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] その後、
[SPEAKER_00] 産業調査部の方で、
[SPEAKER_00] 既に定量分析もすごく進んでいらっしゃると思うので、
[SPEAKER_00] 身につけたヒアリング能力、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] で、
[SPEAKER_00] そういった話だけど、
大企業のアレンジとかでお話ししたことは、
はい。
産業調査部の方と同席をすることが多いというふうに伺っていて、
ほとんど同席の方も、
その辺りの会議で、
[SPEAKER_00] メンターの方にお聞きして、
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね、
[SPEAKER_00] 産業調査部の方で、
[SPEAKER_00] あと、
[SPEAKER_00] 大企業の方に、
[SPEAKER_00] アレンジとか、
[SPEAKER_00] フィニアの大物の時代の時に、
[SPEAKER_00] そういうヒアリング能力を用いて、
[SPEAKER_00] で、
[SPEAKER_00] 産業調査部でレポートを出してもらっていらっしゃると思うんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] このレポートの内容と、
[SPEAKER_00] 大企業の会議の内容というところで、
[SPEAKER_00] 業界の見方が、
[SPEAKER_00] 電波のカタックでできているのかというところ、
[SPEAKER_00] そこの、
[SPEAKER_00] クイッチングという作業と、
[SPEAKER_00] それを、
[SPEAKER_00] 産業調査部について、
[SPEAKER_00] より高度なものを提供できる、
はい。
産業調査部の方で、
力をかけていきたいと考えています。
[SPEAKER_01] 産業調査部以外だと、
[SPEAKER_00] 同じになって、
[SPEAKER_00] 同じくなるんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] 定性分析と定性分析のかけ合わせというのは、
[SPEAKER_00] ある程度フォーマット化というか、
[SPEAKER_00] 本当に分析の効能化になるので、
[SPEAKER_00] これって、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり誰でもできるようになると、
[SPEAKER_00] 個人的にはなってしまうので、
[SPEAKER_00] なので、
[SPEAKER_00] これを、
[SPEAKER_00] この、
[SPEAKER_00] ある程度、
[SPEAKER_00] 信号を使いたいというか、
[SPEAKER_00] できたら、
[SPEAKER_00] 今度は、
[SPEAKER_00] 個別企業に対してもっと深く、
[SPEAKER_00] 提供できるようになりたいと、
[SPEAKER_00] 考えているので、
[SPEAKER_00] それから、
[SPEAKER_00] 法人のレベルのほうに戻って、
[SPEAKER_00] やるんでもいいですし、
[SPEAKER_00] あとは、
[SPEAKER_00] どこかで、
[SPEAKER_00] M&Aとか、
[SPEAKER_00] 資本生産とか、
[SPEAKER_00] そういったお客様に対して、
[SPEAKER_00] 分析をしていくということ、
[SPEAKER_00] これもやっていきたいと思います。
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] レポートとか分析とかを提供することで、
[SPEAKER_01] なんか、
[SPEAKER_01] その先になる、
[SPEAKER_01] お客様に、
[SPEAKER_01] 何を提供したいのかという。
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_00] 顧客満足度は、
[SPEAKER_00] もう、
[SPEAKER_00] 間違いないと思うんですけれども、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり、
[SPEAKER_00] 今まで来てと、
[SPEAKER_00] お客様の、
[SPEAKER_00] 最初に来てしまえば、
[SPEAKER_00] 手を引き上げることだと、
[SPEAKER_00] 思うんですよね。
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] なので、
[SPEAKER_00] その人生を生かして、
[SPEAKER_00] 業績を伸ばして、
[SPEAKER_00] させていただければ、
[SPEAKER_00] いいかなと。
[SPEAKER_01] キャリアのところで言うと、
[SPEAKER_01] ちょうど、
[SPEAKER_01] 応募制度とかで、
[SPEAKER_01] 自分自身で手を挟んで、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
手を挟んで、
ただ、
一方で、
不合格の状況もありますし、
はい。
自分が行きたいと思っていた、
方向、
逆算ズレ、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] まあ、
[SPEAKER_01] なんか、
[SPEAKER_01] 180度全然違うところに、
[SPEAKER_01] 寄せてられることは、
[SPEAKER_01] そんなにないと思うんです。
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] ちょっと違うんだけど、
[SPEAKER_01] みたいな、
[SPEAKER_01] 寄り道か、
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] キャリア、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] かなって、
[SPEAKER_01] 最初、
[SPEAKER_01] 思っちゃうようなところに、
[SPEAKER_01] 移動されることもあるんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] そういうのは、
[SPEAKER_00] どうです、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] まず、
[SPEAKER_00] 今、
[SPEAKER_00] 逆にお話ししたので、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] そこを不安に思われる、
[SPEAKER_00] と思うんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 僕としては、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] いろんな視点を身につけることって、
[SPEAKER_00] 非常に重要で、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 分析するにあたって、
[SPEAKER_00] 思考ロックというか、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 見方が単一になってしまうのは、
[SPEAKER_00] よくないことだと思っているので、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] そこは、
[SPEAKER_00] やはり、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 多角的な視点といいますか、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] いろんな立場での、
[SPEAKER_00] こちら別に、
[SPEAKER_00] うん。
[SPEAKER_00] 例えば、
[SPEAKER_00] 産業調査所に行きたかったり、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 農業調査所に行きたかったり、
[SPEAKER_00] 場合は、
[SPEAKER_00] 場合でも、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] そこで、
[SPEAKER_01] これしか身につけられない視点というのは、
[SPEAKER_01] いや、
[SPEAKER_01] しないと思う。
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_01] 個人RMとして、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 様々な会社、
[SPEAKER_01] 担当することになると思うんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] そうすると、
[SPEAKER_01] その、
[SPEAKER_01] 業績がいい会社ばかりではなくて、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] なかなかもう、
[SPEAKER_01] うん。
[SPEAKER_01] 厳しい会社を担当する人が、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 今あると思っていて、
[SPEAKER_01] えっと、
[SPEAKER_01] お客様としては、
[SPEAKER_01] お貸しできないというのを、
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] はっきり申し上げなきゃいけない局面もあって、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] まあ、
[SPEAKER_01] 社長様も、
[SPEAKER_01] うん。
[SPEAKER_01] ご自身も、
[SPEAKER_01] 生活がかかってるし、
[SPEAKER_01] うん。
[SPEAKER_01] 後ろに控えてる社員がいて、
[SPEAKER_01] そうです、そうです、そうです。
[SPEAKER_01] 分かっていて、
[SPEAKER_01] ものすごく必死だと思うんですが、
[SPEAKER_01] うん。
[SPEAKER_01] お客様としては、
[SPEAKER_01] 貸せないものは貸せないので、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] 面前でしっかりお問い合わせの、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 局面があると思いますけど、
[SPEAKER_01] そういうときは、
[SPEAKER_01] なんかどういうふうに、
[SPEAKER_00] そうですね、あの、
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] その融資できない条件、
[SPEAKER_00] 様々な条件があって、
[SPEAKER_00] クリアできてないから、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 融資お貸しできないっていうのが、
[SPEAKER_00] だと思うんですけど、
はい。
[SPEAKER_00] なので、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] その条件をクリアできるように、
[SPEAKER_00] うん。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] どうすればよいのかっていうことを、
[SPEAKER_00] 一緒に模索していきましょうっていうふうに、
[SPEAKER_00] ご提案させていただくかなと思います。
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] おっしゃっていただいたとおり、
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] じゃあ次はこれやりましょう、
[SPEAKER_01] 一緒にこれやりましょうっていうふうに、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] で、その先に、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] 本社がこれ、
[SPEAKER_01] 成長を描ければ、
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] また、
はい。
新たな方針のところで、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] ずっと2人300で、
はい。
担当していくのかなと思うんですけど、
じゃあ、
今、
[SPEAKER_01] 金貸してくれるっていうふうなところだと思うんですけど、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] そこは、
[SPEAKER_01] まあ、
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] ずっと、
[SPEAKER_01] 2人300で、
[SPEAKER_01] 過去からずっとやってきた、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 銀行の担当者がいうことだからこそ、
[SPEAKER_01] うん。
[SPEAKER_01] ちゃんと聞いてくれるっていう側面もあるかと思うので、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] まあ、
[SPEAKER_01] それまでの間に信頼関係がしてなかったら、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あちこちに、
[SPEAKER_01] 水保第一志望ですとか、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] 無理におっしゃらなくて大丈夫ですが、
[SPEAKER_01] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] かんぽさんもないないでいらっしゃって、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] なんか、
[SPEAKER_00] どうやって決めようかなと思って。
[SPEAKER_00] えっと、
[SPEAKER_00] もう、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 本当に第一志望でして、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり、
[SPEAKER_00] かんぽ生命さんに頂いてる、
[SPEAKER_00] うん。
[SPEAKER_00] 技術戦略部っていうのは、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり、
[SPEAKER_00] それがメインなんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 実際に、
[SPEAKER_00] その、
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] それを、
[SPEAKER_00] こう、
[SPEAKER_00] 巡り巡ってお客様に、
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] なっているようになると思うんですが、
[SPEAKER_00] 実際に、
[SPEAKER_00] お客様に、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 貸し出ししてないというところなので、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] それと比較してみると、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] 法人RMだと、
[SPEAKER_00] 実際にお客様と対面しますし、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] というところで、
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] もう一点、
[SPEAKER_00] その、
[SPEAKER_00] こう、
[SPEAKER_00] 身につけることができるのっていうのは、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり、
[SPEAKER_00] お客様に対応してないとできないことだと、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 考えていますので、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] お客様と実際に対面することがない、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] 戦略部ではなくて、
[SPEAKER_00] 銀行の、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] やっぱり、
他のメガバンクさんでもできると思います。
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] あの、
[SPEAKER_01] 他のメガバンクは、
エントリーしてないんですか?
[SPEAKER_00] 確かに、
[SPEAKER_00] エントリーしたんですけれども、
[SPEAKER_00] あ、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_01] 不合格、
[SPEAKER_01] あ、
[SPEAKER_01] OKです。
[SPEAKER_01] 了解です。
[SPEAKER_01] へー、
[SPEAKER_01] もう、
[SPEAKER_01] 何かストレス溜まるときは?
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] そう、
[SPEAKER_00] はい。
[SPEAKER_00] まあ、
[SPEAKER_00] ストレスを、
[SPEAKER_00] その、
[SPEAKER_00] 失敗したときとかは、
[SPEAKER_00] やっぱり、
[SPEAKER_00] かなり落ち込むというか、
[SPEAKER_00] 引きずる、
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_00] ああ、
[SPEAKER_01] で、
[SPEAKER_01] さっきの、
[SPEAKER_00] あの、
[SPEAKER_00] 目で見比べて、
[SPEAKER_00] そう、
[SPEAKER_01] そうですね。
[SPEAKER_01] あ、
[SPEAKER_00] あのときは、
[SPEAKER_00] もともと、
[SPEAKER_00] 1週間ぐらい、
[SPEAKER_00] 結構、
[SPEAKER_00] 引きずったんですけど、
[SPEAKER_00] 中でやっぱり引きずりながら
[SPEAKER_00] 仕事するというのも結構大変でしたが
[SPEAKER_00] 割と寝たら
[SPEAKER_00] 気持ちがすっきりする
[SPEAKER_00] 方なので
[SPEAKER_00] しっかり睡眠をとること
[SPEAKER_00] ちゃんと生活リズムよく
[SPEAKER_00] ちゃんと寝ること
[SPEAKER_00] それが
[SPEAKER_00] ストレス発散です
[SPEAKER_01] 寝たら忘れるけど
[SPEAKER_01] 1週間引きずった
[SPEAKER_00] 寝たら忘れるのに
[SPEAKER_00] 1週間も引きずった
[SPEAKER_00] かなりダメージを受けた
[SPEAKER_01] そうですか
[SPEAKER_01] それがやっぱり
[SPEAKER_01] 脳機に遅れちゃって
[SPEAKER_01] 上司に迷惑をかけた
[SPEAKER_01] それは絶対に
[SPEAKER_01] ずらしちゃいけないの?
[SPEAKER_00] そんなことはなく
[SPEAKER_00] 上司が
[SPEAKER_00] クライアントさんと
[SPEAKER_00] 連絡を取って
[SPEAKER_00] 期待値を
[SPEAKER_00] うまく調整してくださったんですけれども
[SPEAKER_00] でもやっぱり
[SPEAKER_00] ここまでと言われされて
[SPEAKER_00] やりきれなかったというか
[SPEAKER_00] 信頼して投げてくださった仕事を
[SPEAKER_00] やりきれなかったというのは
[SPEAKER_00] 悔しいですし
[SPEAKER_00] 期待を裏切る結果になってしまったので
[SPEAKER_00] ここはきっちりやりたかったなと思います
ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_01] ではお伺いしたい方に
[SPEAKER_01] お聞きできましたら
どうもありがとうございました
本日は結果をこの場で申し上げないと
ごめんなさい
最初に言うときは
すみません
次のステップに進んでいただく
もしくは6月の場合
6月の20日
[SPEAKER_00] ありがとうございます
[SPEAKER_00] では
電話で
はい
ありがとうございます
ではお時間いただいて
いろいろとしていただきありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
はい
お疲れ様です
ありがとうございました